On a donc reporté la chirurgie de la main.
Moi et mon bassin fracturé étions donc coincés six semaines au lit
et ça m'aurait rendue complètement folle, si je n'avais pas eu des amis formidables.
Tous les soirs, des soirées étaient spontanément organisées à la maison.
On m'a nourrie et amusée.
C'était super.
Mais ce genre d'enthousiasme est difficile à entretenir à long terme.
À la fin, il n'y avait plus qu'un seul ami
qui m'envoyait des blagues en journée
et qui venait me tenir compagnie les soirées.
Une personne que j'ai appris à mieux connaitre pendant ma convalescence.
Dès qu'on m'eut déclarée en état de santé suffisant
pour reprendre des exercices,
on a mis le télescope dans le coffre et on est parti en montagne
pour observer la comète Hale-Bopp.
Oui, on est des geeks.
Et on s'est retrouvé pris dans un glissement de terrain.
(Rires)
Je sais, c'est dingue, non ?
Oui. C'était une plaisanterie.
(Rires)
Plus de catastrophe. Tout le contraire.
C'était il y a 21 ans,
et depuis 19 ans
je suis mariée à cet introverti fabuleux
qui était à des années-lumière de m'approcher,
n'eussent été ces circonstances.
Nous avons une fille merveilleuse de 14 ans,
qui a réalisé ces illustrations.
(Encouragements et applaudissements)
Oui.
Alors, astuce de pro :
Il semblerait que rien ne rende plus sexy qu'un déambulateur
au premier rendez-vous.
Mon histoire ne parle donc pas d'épines,
de requins, de cuisson ou de rupture.
C'est une histoire d'amour.
C'est une histoire d'amour avec une fin cocasse.
Une fois de ma fracture du bassin, je pouvais reprogrammer la chirurgie
pour extraire cette épine.
Mais ce n'était plus nécessaire.
En fait, quand on a une fracture,
l'organisme réquisitionne tout le calcium disponible dans tous les os du corps,
ainsi que la petite épine d'oursin qui est restée par hasard
dans l'articulation de mon doigt.
Alors voilà,
mon bassin est maintenant en parti constitué d'oursin.
(Rires)
Alors, à mon cerveau de biologiste et de physicienne,
d'accro à l'adrénaline et de mammifère au sang chaud,
je peux ajouter « cerveau d'oursin »
avec tous les pouvoirs surnaturels qui viennent avec.
Ne vous inquiétez pas.
Ne pas être totalement humaine est une des choses
que ma famille adore chez moi.
(Rires)
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)